on August 21st darkness will wash over
America but in a good way we promise if
the total solar eclipse the first to hit
the US mainland in almost four decades
the shadow will cut a path 70 miles wide
he's getting an Oregon at about 10 a.m.
local time from there it'll move into
Idaho and Wyoming then pass through the
Midwest before leaving the US through
South Carolina at 2:45 Eastern the total
eclipse will only last a few minutes in
a given spot but if you happen to have a
jet like NASA does you can race the shot
in the name of science NASA will be able
to observe the eclipses for seven
minutes
the best the rest of us loves can manage
is driving to the eclipses path but be
forewarned a lot of people are going to
have the same idea 12 million people
already live in the path of the Eclipse
but as many as 7 million will make the
trek to these areas even if you can't
make it to see the totality you'll be
treated to a partial solar eclipse the
closer you are to the path the more
complete via clips will be at work here
is a supreme astronomical coincidence
the moon is of course much much smaller
than the Sun but because it's so much
closer the two bodies actually appear to
us observers on earth as the same size
so when the moon passes in front of the
Sun it perfectly obscures the star
what's important to remember is that
while you can look at a total solar
eclipse without burning your eyes out of
your head to watch a partial eclipse
you're going to need special glasses
these use a thin layer of aluminum or
silver to block the nasty energy coming
off the Sun you can get these any number
of places online don't you dare try
watching without after all if you want
to watch the next solar eclipse that'll
hit the US in 2024 you're going to need
to see it or if you've been planning a
South American getaway do it in 2019 for
their next totality just don't forget
your shades